what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss
one of if not the most shocking chapter
of one piece
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button
until it changes color if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one piece videos and while you
wait for the next chapter to come out
and there will be a break next week feel
free to check out my growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all
yonko
warlords supernova and more link to that
is in the description also let me know
if there's a one piece topic you're
burning up to see that i haven't covered
yet in the playlist
now without further ado let's jump into
it
this chapter is called big mom's anarchy
and we left off last chapter at a point
where the focus was on nami and ulti in
what big mom would do
so with a title like this we can bet
it's gonna be
big tsunami attacked ulti last chapter
which was one of her most epic moments
as she stood up for tama
despite usually being just as scared of
zusap yeah she's scared but if you cross
the line
in certain ways her own life is no
longer the priority for nami and it's
such moments that make me love nami
all the more the fact that she's
gorgeous doesn't hurt either as
usopp is trying to convince her that
they need to go
nami says that she doesn't care about
running all she cares about is putting
ulti in her place
after she hurt tama as tama is
unconscious
in usop's arms big mom is visibly
concerned about tama begging to know if
her little friend is okay
ulti quickly recovers and grabs nami
holding her in place
with her giant dino body that towers
over nami's
as she wanted to do for so long ulti is
finally going to cave in nami's head
that would no doubt be the end of her
and nami was ready for that
but just then as we might have expected
big mom finally steps in
she combines napoleon prometheus and her
new
thundercloud hera into a combo attack
called
mazer cannon if that's how you pronounce
it which is apparently the ultimate
weapon
from the godzilla series quite the
perfect name when you're fighting a
dinosaur-esque creature
of course ulti had no chance against
this kind of focused yonko attack and
it's straight up looks like she's done
for
with oda you never know for sure if
someone is dead
but this kind of move could definitely
get the job done let me know is ulti
done
in your view or will she come back again
but maybe after this
war now the audience is freaking out
because not only did big mom take out
one flying six member namely page one
but now she took out
two including ulti as well these guys
aren't fodder
so big mom is really throwing a wrench
into this flimsy alliance
now usop and nami after acknowledging
how nuts this
is take the opportunity and attempt to
escape
and sadly they have to leave komachio
behind
zeus finally pops up for nami to see
making nami wonder about the other
thunder cloud she saw
namely hera it turns out that prometheus
asked big mom for a girlfriend
probably throwing in that zeus is
useless and needs to be replaced too and
hera was the result
sadly for prometheus hera is not
interested a pretty hilarious touch
you gotta feel bad for zeus here though
as he's crying and looking at how
complete they all look together without
him as
zeus gets excited when he sees nami nami
looks away
still upset that zeus had turned against
her so now zeus is
ever so alone and lonely pathetic
fallacy at its finest
poor zeus tries to rejoin big mom and
the rest while big mom states that his
services will no longer be required she
doesn't just fire
him though she wants his life too big
mom wants hera to eat him so she'll be
stronger
zeus crying rain begs for his life
promising to leave and to never show
himself again but big mom is not cool
with this and it kind of makes sense
because he'd be running away with a part
of her soul
in the meantime big mom takes tama from
our straw hats wanting to protect her
thomas states that the straw hats are
her friends so we'll finally see how
this dynamic is going to pan out
in the meantime zeus apologizes to nami
for trying to kill her
and states he was too cowardly to defy
big mom
he acknowledges he was pathetic and
spineless but if this
is the end he wants to die without being
all alone without being hated by
everyone
for nami's sake he commits his so-called
first and last act of defiance against
big mom
trying to make amends with nami even if
it costs him his life he's committed to
helping nami escape
unfortunately despite nami trying to
help him it appears that zeus does get
eaten with big mom's help
i'm hoping it's not over though since we
all know zeus
is so perfect for nami especially now
after this brave stand
zeus has definitely grown on me over the
chapters and i definitely want to see
a lot more of him in the future then big
mom freaks out on tama because she sees
tama running away if you checked out my
every yonko's backstory explained video
link in the description you know that
because of her past big mom is
traumatized by the idea of people
leaving her
especially people she cares deeply about
so it's not surprising even if i didn't
see it coming that she
asks whether she has to kill tama for
running away and then we get
our boy kid getting his chance to shine
i love this dude and with his giant
metallic
arm he slams a yonko into the ground
so epic so hype he tells the straw hats
to beat it after saving them adding that
this yonko is his
prey yonko hunter kid is in the house
and he
timed this perfectly meaning after big
mom had taken out ulti for them
and after she had turned against the
straw hats this was already a great
chapter but it's not over
in just two pages the final two pages
oda shows us something
truly shocking kaido has apparently
finished off luffy for the second time
he talks about how he got too confident
just cause he learned one new move
he says something pretty profound namely
that humans always cling on to faith
in a way they can't afford to abandon it
and that can be dangerous
he seems to be totally fine but he does
pay luffy the compliment of saying it's
been a while since he got
this fired up and laments making the
mistake of not taking luffy's head as a
trophy
so here it seems clear that kaido had a
chance to finish off luffy for good
and take his head so that he could show
everyone as proof which he wishes he had
done because the idea of luffy
and what he represents is so strong that
people's faith in him will never die
without proof
we see luffy unconscious beaten and
falling off this
island into the sea below which we all
know means death to any fruit user
now will luffy die of course there is no
way of that happening
even if oda is making it look like that
might be possible right now we gotta
remember this is a shonen series about
how luffy will become the pirate king so
he'll definitely survive
whether he extends his arms to get back
up or someone saves him
however even if he doesn't die it's
crazy to see kaido do this a second time
after all of luffy's training
and if we believe kaido he could have
finished off luffy
if he just took his head off when he had
the chance
they do say the third time is the charm
but when is that third time gonna be
soon or somewhere down the line i'm not
sure i think we're all pretty shocked by
this turn of events after luffy seemed
so confident last time however at the
same time i like the fact that oda is
giving the yonko and the strongest
creature in the world
the respect they deserve by not making
it easy for luffy to win
i was saying before that luffy appeared
to be leveling up a bit
quickly before which is kind of
ridiculous considering how long one
piece has been going on and yet
oda still seemed to address my concern
by reminding us that beating a yonko
won't be that easy
storytelling wise this is great stuff
and all of this struggling and temporary
failure means that luffy's eventual
victory will be
all the more satisfying let me know your
thoughts about this absolutely
insane chapter and what you expect to
happen next
as far as we know luffy and zoro are out
of commission right now
which is not a good sign in addition to
figuring out how luffy survives i can't
wait to see
kid show us something special since i
think oda is finally gonna give him his
chance to shine in this arc not that he
didn't do a great job in this chapter
but i think he'll wow us even more in
the following ones you gotta give it to
oda another emotional chapter that has
me on the edge of my seat
anyways thanks again for watching and
let me know who the mvp was in this
chapter
it's probably between zeus and captain
kidd for me
zeus had more moments but wow that yonko
slam was just
so awesome if you do enjoy these
one-piece reviews and want to keep them
coming
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button
until it changes color if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications because there are many
more one piece videos on the way
and while you wait for the next chapter
to come out and just a reminder there
will be a break next week
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist that includes videos on
all yonko warlord supernova and more
link to that is in the description also
let me know if there's a one piece topic
you're burning up to see
that i haven't yet covered in the
playlist and i especially want to thank
the patron squad over on patreon and
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patrons of
legend the ones acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself
alpha sigma and red haired raven and are
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
on top all clans ingrata pate hepa
al-jatal
dr cortman the toasted chi ry carlo
emperor otaku spidey life tennelle
tungsten tarkis and
cody hebert and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz anatoly kozadski cricket xp
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami and water
ted no ted i sparky65 joey garcia fat
boy games
metal mama corey mcgowan deadly saints
soul ride slice and dice and
pill you thank you all so much if you do
enjoy our work you can support morbid by
going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
the latest chapters
the latest anime seasons life and of
course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue
join button right next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully already
destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you